we're ready now you've got your screen
there at the reading you've got your
ruler but you've got to use for quite a
few of these things let's have a look at
the question so I've got my questions
over here because I can't have both on
the same time okay so this is question 2
so let's just start by saying parte 1 of
the dimensions of the block okay so
you've got the easy part first that they
actually give you over here on the right
hand side can you see it they give you
those 20 meters but then they haven't
provided the other will they have
provided the width of the block for you
do you see that so you're going to need
to get your ruler out and you're going
to need to measure in centimeters or
millimeters whichever you prefer you're
going to need to measure all the way
across so you have this distance okay
now i actually heard it when I measured
it I got nine point nine centimeters
okay so stay with me Shh when we're mad
remember when we're looking at scale you
might need to write this down on the
bottom here to remind yourself that
scale is equal to its a fraction do you
remember that what's it over whatever
what remember yeah it's the drawings
late / the reality the real legs right
so you might like to put that down here
drawing over reality ok now the scale is
told to us right it's one to four
hundred so in order to get from the
drawing that nine point nine centimeters
so how wide it's supposed to be in
reality this is part a I guess I would
say the weird that's what I'm going to
call this or with the block because
there's a width of a whole bunch of
things the winner of the block is going
to be the distance i measured that nine
point nine centimeters note the units
and remember we said this thing's
supposed to be four hundred times bigger
in reality so i'm going to multiply by
four hundred okay so one thing that's
nice there is that you can see over i'll
just zoom in for a second you can see
i'm going to multiply by four hundred
i'm gonna do is quite a lot multiplying
by a hundred is the same as changing
from centimeters the unit i have two
meters right so i suppose if you want
you can write this down below this nine
point nine centimeters is going to
become nine point nine meters times four
does that make sense you see how I dealt
with the 100 and I use it to convert
centimeters to meters ok now you can
then go to your calculator you should be
able to check I'm pretty sure that's
39.6 meters ok one of the ways i checked
out quickly is it's close to 10 right
it's close to 10 so if it's pretty much
10 10 times 4 40 but you take off a
little bit and that's a little bit you
take ok right so I've used my ruler to
measure find out the width of the block
have I answered the question not quite I
need the dimensions right so i would say
therefore the dimensions are and because
it's something with our length and width
i'm going to provide both of those so i
would say 39.6 meters by 20 meters
because they already told us it to me ok
all right that's not too hard so now the
next question is much in the same style
so it says rather than the dimensions of
the block find the length of the
driveway to garage so you can see where
it is again I'd like you to measure and
just like we did before you want to get
it in reality so you'll need to multiply
whatever you measure by 400 can you have
a go which is in roller up and see what
you get
because in this book right like they've
actually printed this book up right and
they've printed it such that this is one
centimeter and then off the basis of
that dissent okay you know what this
scale is one to four hundred and in this
book it doesn't change right but then of
course we come with our fancy technology
and depend on what you're looking at it
will be bigger or smaller so it's a
longer one to four hundred if I'm you
know if I'm this right it's huge yeah
yeah so that's why I had to make it um
the same size is this
okay so who's measured it out then
someone measured it out 6.5 okay six my
force it right now it's worth pointing
out right because we looked at this back
in mm one that we're all using something
like this right so clearly this has
error built into it yeah mine has the
units that I've got our millimeters so
what does that mean about my
measurements does that mean what's my
what's my margin of error what's the
greatest possible error it's half a
millimeter right but it's half a
millimeter plus or minus so if someone
measures 6.5 and another person measure
6.4 actually that's exactly what we
would expect right there's that 11
millimeter of difference that we're just
not sure about okay by the way it's
worth mentioning in an exam they have to
take this into account and there are
questions just like it's at the HRC we
have to accept a range of responses okay
in fact when I have a book so my answers
disagreed with the textbooks but they'll
only be off by whatever that amount so
um let's go with 6.5 i'm going to say
driveway because that's what I'm working
up it's the Ranger like
you good question well let's look down
to that right now so i have calculated
6.5 centimeters times 400 i think that
ends up being what 26 someone calculator
already I yeah isn't 26 yeah okay 26
meters okay now hold on a second let's
just think about it if I had measured
six point four centimeters instead of
6.5 then I x 400 so how far will I be
off in the final number in the real
number hmm off by one millimeter here
but I multiply that by four hundred
right let me write that down by the era
yeah good you got it so the air are
right in the measured drawing right it's
going to be 0.1 centimeters is not there
which is in community but when i
multiply it by 400 that's going to be 40
centimeters right so therefore you might
get 26 meters or you might get 20 5.6
meters and they're both within that
error okay right let's have a look keep
going we've got some more measures to do
and some of these are a bit some of them
a tricky some of them are given to you
Patsy says determine the distance
between the house and the fence so can
you see on the block as a fence going
all the way around it's in pink and then
it asks you on the northern boundary and
there's a compass just over there in
left hand side in case you hadn't
noticed it and on the southern boundary
okay now they actually have given you
these distances look carefully you don't
have to measure these with a rule lot
the first one on the northern boundary
is two meters so you can state that plot
see part 1 2 meters for Part C Part 2
where am I going to look the driveway is
the width between the southern sorry
between the fence and the southern
boundary okay so all I need to state for
Part C Part 2 he is 4 meters okay
I four meters four meters bull I'm going
four meters four meters there's four
steps here so I guess it'd be something
like one two three yes it's interesting
just earlier today I was in a year a
clot and I was asking him to cut out a
piece of paper that was as close as they
could estimate with no you know objects
like this a hundred square centimeters
now we've been doing plenty of
measurement right if I ask you for a
square how wide are the sides for a 100
square centimeter square it's going to
be yet 10 by 10 and the smallest square
someone did I think was like 80 and the
biggest one was like 300 so we're pretty
bad at estimating because we don't often
do it right which is the whole point of
it okay I'm pardine pardis another one
you can just read off right Pardy how
far is the house from the street it's
just six meters I'm just looking at it
over there after that I think most of
the ones that you can just read off they
em so we need our ruler again Part F
says owner is a party yeah okay party
now you have to be pretty careful here
because it's such a small distance so
the error as a percentage remember this
we looked at absolute error and
percentage error is going to be quite
large so do your best measure from the
garage to the southern boundary and see
what you get there are bushes in the way